it never stops they're telling people to
stay indoors this is what a total
lockdown looks like in the center of the
corona virus epidemic in Italy
this is bergamot the dead center it's
quite scary you don't really get used to
it it is apocalyptic and of course here
they're calling it the apocalypse it
doesn't feel that life here will ever be
the same again in the total lockdown
volunteers take food and supplies to the
most vulnerable the old and the already
sick they also take medicine to those
who would simply die they were infected
Valentino trivia lost his uncle to the
virus this week like so many he wants to
help
like so many he's broken inside ok
I'm saying
estamos antenna MultiJet aqui y ND
filter and all regatta initial una
pesadilla are you
the mayor Giorgio Gauri who brought his
daughters home from the UK so they could
live under the lockdown in Italy because
it's safer is working 20 hours a day he
admits he's obsessed with co-ed 19 data
contacting the mayors of other towns and
building a picture of the actual death
right here
there isn't any official study on this
he's convinced the official numbers are
an underestimate because too many deaths
aren't being included the number of dead
may actually be higher yeah why is that
in this moment only people with heart
symptoms are tested in India hospital if
you are with a high temperature in your
home with cough no you are not detected
the doctor will say you stay at home
take the hideous medicine and if you
breathe quite well you don't need to be
recovered and bring to the road to the
hospital so you are not that in in in
the not a statistic right
if you die in this country in this
condition you are out of the rather no
you are not considered as died for
coronavirus
recent figures have indicated the death
and infection rates are slowing but in
reality you'd never know the sirens
never stopped another ambulance passes
it's an absolute constant in the in the
red zone people are still being picked
up yeah all the time you will pass
ambulance system literally if you stand
still an adverse or party every five
minutes lights on and the drivers in
full hazmat suits it's quite astounding
[Music]
there is clearly a very long way to go
overnight the military cleared the
bodies from the hospital morgue in the
town because it was full this is the
next day the morgue is already filling
up it seems absolutely endless
Stuart Ramsey Sky News bergamo italy